James Charles loses nearly 2 million
YouTube subscribers in less than two
days it's gonna be like the downfall of
your career don't do it to talk to you
James
Westbrook I'm sorry for everything that
is going on everything that I have put
you through over the past few weeks
let's rewind before that apology video
was shared to James's YouTube account
early Saturday beauty blogger Tati
Westbrook broke the internet with a
forty three minute long confessional
titled by sister chronicling why she is
cutting ties with her former sister
which ultimately led to James's
dwindling follower count as his ego is
so big that he will think that
everything is about him I absolutely
loved James Charles my husband loved
James Charles he had an open door here
in my home anytime he had a problem
anytime he needed life advice business
advice you know we were we were here for
him I've promoted him I have supported
him James and Tati have been friends for
three years
James appearing several times on her
channel he did her wedding makeup and
from what Tati claims her husband even
helped James secure major beauty deals
and I was constantly like you're
talented you've got this keep going what
do you need how can I help you anytime
that James would need help he'd be like
dad what should I do your family how can
I help you
[Music]
the pair's feud reportedly heated up in
April when James promoted a supplement
company on his Instagram stories that
rivals Tottie's brand halo Beauty Tati
accused him of betraying her over that
post which he later apologized for I'm
so disappointed in myself
Tati is also claiming the 19 year old
beauty guru has been spreading lies
about her and criticized his off-camera
behavior oh my god you tried to trick a
straight man into thinking he's gay yet
again and somehow you're the victim I've
been involved a lot of very unique and
strange situations that I've left people
confused or upset and I've learned the
hard way about ways that I can interact
with boys that I'm interested in and
also one that I should or shouldn't be
talking to it's plain that I should have
been far more careful with James's
follower count has dropped and continues
to Tati's account is flourishing going
from five point nine million subscribers
to eight point six million as of Sunday
according to Newsweek those who have
unfollowed Charles since Friday include
Miley Cyrus Kylie Jenner Katy Perry
Demi Lovato and Shawn Mendes who he
reportedly had a feud with at one point
we doing back and forth a few times no
flirting unfortunately for me but here's
super super sweet although James
apologized for his actions in his video
labeled Tati I'm definitely really
careful about my platform and who I'm
affecting and what I'm saying on it
because I want to be the best role model
stars still weighed in on the situation
Jeffrey star backed up Tati saying her
claims are 100% true about James so you
learned a life lesson yeah
zara larsson alleged on Twitter James
once slid into her boyfriend Brian
Whitaker's DMS on Instagram and the
second most followed youtuber online
PewDiePie also weighed in entitled his
reaction video James Charles is canceled
James Charles biggest oopsie of 2019
James Charles whatever scandal similar
to the one he's had before James Charles
absolutely not ba ba ba ba ba ba Papa
Papa I wish that I could say this is the
last time that I would make a mistake
the story is still unfolding make sure
to stay tuned to ET online for the
latest updates
I'm just handling it day by day and
trying my absolute best and of course
learning for my mistakes and it's a
learning process there's no guide book
on how to do this it's just be yourself
and hopefully people yeah are there for
the ride